Trump attorney Joe takapina you know my
first question is you know considering
you know Mueller was against this uh the
doj was against it the FEC was against
it Cyrus Vance was against us and even
Alvin Bragg when he first took office
seemed against this my question is now
the brag showed his great courage is he
going to get in the courtroom with Joe
takapina is he going to try this case
start to finish
oh he'll be in the courtroom I think
he'll be about three or four rows back
um but when when and if the bell rings
at a trial in this case I have a hunch
he's he's going to be a spectator not a
participant uh you know I I agree with
you it would be the courageous thing to
do when you're doing something so
historic so Monumental
um bringing an indictment against the
first former president in in the history
of this country
um you know you should try that yourself
being that you're the one who's you know
pulling those strings but I I can't
imagine that happening of course I would
welcome that but I can't imagine it
happening Sean all right let's go
through what the day will be like
tomorrow reports are that you and the
president will arrive I assume others
will be with the president at about 11
A.M he'll be before a judge around 2 15.
we know that the president will get a
mug shot we know he will be
fingerprinted is he going to be perp
walk do we have any guarantee they won't
do that uh will he be handcuffed do we
have any guarantee they won't do that uh
any anything extraordinary that you
expect tomorrow or is it all planned out
what's extraordinary is that tomorrow's
actually happening that's what's
extraordinary I I just cannot believe
beyond that point I agree on the Eve of
Destruction like yeah you know it's just
like surreal to me based on this charge
these allegations it's a federal
election committee and a little a
federal election law rule that governs
here here's a state prosecutor when
Federal the FEC has turned this down the
the federal prosecutors have turned us
down and when it looked at his turn down
said there's no violation here a state
prosecutor is now going to bring a case
based on a federal law violation that
doesn't exist according to the federal
authorities
um it's it's surreal it's shocking but
you know look we don't know what's going
to happen tomorrow other than that we'll
be pleading very loudly not guilty
before the judge
um and then we'll go from there all
right let me ask you there's been a lot
of reports today that there might be a
gag order placed on Donald Trump a
presidential candidate that has happened
in the past Roger Stone I think manafort
I don't fully remember but I know what
happened in Stone's case are you telling
me there's a possibility that they would
prevent a presidential candidate from
using his Free Speech rights and
defending himself
can't be won't happen
um I don't believe anyone's even looking
for that I mean that would be that would
really
set a blaze the the passions and the
tempers that already have been inflamed
by this case
um you know people view this as a
political persecution you know those
numbers you showed Sean in your
introduction regarding his increase in
in popularity in the polls and the
amount of money that's come in the last
three days are because people are
infuriated and they are now
understanding that weaponization of the
justice system is a real thing but you
know attempting to gag a United States
citizen who was a defendant not a lawyer
not a litigant but but a defendant in
the case
um you know especially that's a First
Amendment violation obviously but has to
be balanced against the a right to a
fair trial but imagine putting a gag on
Donald Trump when he's the front runner
for the Republican Party
um for the presidential office and and
imagine during the campaign he's told
you know I can't speak about the case so
when people ask him questions he has to
just say sorry I have a gag order
obviously that's not going to happen
that would directly interfere with the
election as this prosecution has already
done that would further interfere with
the election there's no scenario where
that's going to happen I'm sure of that
I don't think that's even going to be
requested all right let me let me ask
this I know the president said he
doesn't believe he can get a fair trial
you've tried over a hundred cases in New
York City over the course of your career
very successfully in most instances my
question to you is this is a city where
Democrats outnumber Republicans nearly
ten to one I mean you've got a seated
jury the odds are the overwhelming
number of potential jurors in this case
are going to be registered Democrats
Democrats in this country they seem to
bubble and Fizz like Alka-Seltzer and
water just at the very name Donald Trump
or the face of Donald Trump
so I wonder I mean you don't have to
give away your strategy but but I have
doubts if he can get a fair trial here I
really do and why not have a change of
venue to make sure that it's in you know
at least a 50 50 part of New York State
we're absolutely going to obviously
consider all things you know we the
legal team has been meeting and
discussing and and they'll be a host of
motions we're going to make including
I'm telling you right off the bat a
motion to dismiss based on uh selective
prosecution prosecutor misconduct there
will be those other things considered
like a venue change and other motions
that wouldn't be right to get into at
this point we first have to see this
indictment
um but but you know look at the end of
the day when if this gets to a jury and
it really shouldn't get to a jury
because this case should be dismissed on
the law but if it gets to a jury
you know what I would do what our team
would do with Todd and Susan would do is
simply look you know the drawers in the
eyes and say this is you understand
you're not voting for political office
here this is not a presidential campaign
or a gubernatorial campaign this is
someone's life in Liberty and and this
is much more serious than what side of
the the you know political Specter
you're on this is someone's life in
Liberty and whether they're deemed a
criminal for the rest of their life and
most people that that want to be able to
look themselves in the mirror for the
rest of their lives are going to follow
the law and and going to follow the
facts if they follow the law on the
facts in this case if we get to a jury
again
um this should be the quickest verdict
in the history of the United States of
America
um so I I look we have to weigh all
things and we do have to consider the
bias against President Trump in the city
um and we will weigh it um but but
ultimately people who are going to be
sitting in Judgment of him if it gets
that far are going to really have to be
so conscientious of their oath and their
Duty and and the rule of law in this
country because if we just say ah it's
Donald Trump we don't have to worry
about it like you said there's a
republican prosecutor in Texas that's
going to be gearing up for a Democrat
now and this is what we're going to use
the justice system for to to be a
political tool in this country and and
rule of law is dead dead if that
happened Sean you've said a number of
times in this interview if they get that
far are you not expecting it to get that
far
let me be very clear the only reason it
would not get that far is because the
case will be dismissed on papers okay
there is zero zero chance where Donald
Trump is pleading to anything here he
committed no crime he committed no wrong
not a misdemeanor not a felony not a
traffic ticket there is nothing here so
I am talking about this case should fall
on the law and and we're going to be
pushing that obviously
um we have to evaluate everything
including the indictment but I I still
can't believe
um this is going to survive our our
vigorous motions
um to dismiss let's talk about the
statute of limitations the New York
state law which is a misdemeanor and
this unprecedented novel idea never has
been used before of marrying it to an
election law a federal election law uh
will you do you think the statute of
limitations has expired on both the
state law and the federal level
so there's misdemeanors and there's
felonies right statute of limitations
misdemeanors are two years for felonies
in New York state they're five
um there's a question as to whether
um Governor Cuomo's extension of the
statute of limitations by a year and 45
days during the covert period will hold
um even with that it's very close and
the match has to be done there's a lot
of exemptions a lot of issues that is
one of the things so we're going to be
looking at I mean this is this is the
oldest case in the books of all the
things they were investigating and It
just strikes me as so incredibly odd
that they're going to bring Case that's
weak on the law that's going to have
problems surviving serious motions
um that is this old that is this Petty
that has nothing to do with the election
or the campaign but was it personal
civil settlement that's done every day
that was done between a lawyer and
another lawyer when they orchestrated a
a settlement Arrangement that the
president wasn't even privy to at the
time uh he didn't even sign the
settlement agreement and subsequently
later while he was already in office his
organization uh paid some legal fees for
that as they were invoiced it's amazing
amazing to think that this is a a case
that they believe falls under the FEC
rules and regulations the federal
election committee's rules and
regulations and violates any of those
laws it does not not by a long shot and
we've been with some terrific FEC people
Bradley Smith and I have spoken and and
he's confirmed that
um so it is I really just don't know
where they think they're going to wind
up here if it was just to get the you
know 15 minutes tomorrow to get him into
a courtroom and whatnot who knows
let me ask you a final question uh
considering we all know what Bragg said
he ran a campaign to get Donald Trump
one man one company the Trump
organization one family the Trump family
do you believe that this is selective
prosecution and prosecutorial uh abuse
on his part and is there any remedy for
you on on that level
of course that is why it is selective
prosecution
um you know again if he was not named
Donald Trump there would be no
indictment that's a fact I've said it to
you many times I saw Andrew McCarthy I
think Echo that there would not be a
case if this wasn't Donald Trump you
know and and so that's where you know
we're really gone amok here you select
the person that you don't like Donald
Trump and then you try and find a crime
so it is is mind-boggling to me that
that we're here we are here
um but it's it's just not going to hold
up so these these you know charged that
cobbling together to try and make
felonies out of
um won't survive a challenge a legal
challenge all right Joe takapina the
president's attorney thank you for being
here and we'll be watching tomorrow and
get reaction from you tomorrow night hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else